je peux vous me dites la vérité je me
non non PASAT trist je te dis tu es
journaliste indépendant tu as euh mine
de rien des idées voilà plus proche de
Gilles Verdez et que et je je te dis la
vérité je cherche actuellement peut-être
quelqu'un de de ce profil pour mon
émission du weekend est-ce que toi ça te
dirait de V venir donner ton avis ou pas
du tout ça dépend des conditions alors
j'ai pas
d'argent c'est quoi les conditions
condition moi les conditions c'est
simple tu dis vraiment ce que tu penses
liberté de parole totale et si je suis
pas d'accord avec toi
cil moi aussi si je suis pas d'accord
avec toi je peux te le don ah mais moi
alors je te dis un truc et tu Gill c'est
bien passé pouron ça vair g est-ce que
tu peux dire est-ce que je t'ai déjà dit
même même si on se prend la tête est-ce
que je t'ai déjà dit un truc avant
l'émissionou après l'émission jamais
connu une liberté de parole tel qu'ici
et pourtant j'ai ton âge tu peut dire ce
qu'on veut après tu as de la
contradiction et tu peux dire ce que tu
veux jamais j'ai été briefé avant
pendant
après non non viens viens franchement
viens mais viens bah viens viens viens
viens viens S plus tu me laisses combien
de temps pour réfléchir pour réfléchir
demain tu me dis je me dis demain parce
qu'on ce serait bien que tu me dises
avant avant mer il te propose un travail
et tu veux réfléchir non mais bien sûr
il a
Rais j'habite pas iciou ou j'habite à
côté de Toulouse ils vont s'occuper du
trainup il vont s'uper
TR et tu seras comme les autres
chroniqueurs tu sais que les autres
chroniqueurs qui viennent de loin je
leur pe l'hôtel et et le train je te dis
quoi de ma matin bah réfléchis au pire
des cas tu sais ce que tu fais tu viens
tuessayes et si ça te plaît pas tu me
dis non ça m'a pas plu moi que avvoir
une liberté de parole totale pas
d'accord avec
toi pas de souci je dis mais ouais mais
pas de problème mais par contre je
supporterai pas forcément ce que tu
balances à Gilles si tu m'enat dans son
temps alors Gilles c'est un très bon
pote donc je me permets e tu as bien vu
Gill g Gill sain c'est au-delà de de mon
chroniqueur c'est comme je le dis à
chaque fois c'est peut-être celui que
j'aime le plus dans l'émission donc
c'est pour ça que je me permets et il
sait que voilà Gill voilà voilà dès que
je fais un truc c'est lui que j'invite
en premier c'est voilà j'ai des
relations avec Gill qui sont pas pareil
qu'avec toi je te connais pas aussi bien
donc forcément déjà je sais pas si tu es
avec Fatou ou
pas voilà donc je serais pas je Seris
pas forcément mais Patrice tu sais quoi
même moi peut-être que même moi je te le
dis peut-être que même moi peut-être que
je vais dire non ça l'a pas fait tuas
pas tuas pas ta place Tonon le truc si
on voit que ça marche et moi j'hésiterai
pas dire aussi j'hésiterai pas te dire
aussi non franchement Patrice tu as pas
été tu as pas on l'a pas senti ou un
truc comme ça juste fais-toi plaisir dis
ce que tu penses tu viens donner ton
avis parce que moi tu sais j'aime bien
avir tous les avis au contraire autour
de la table et l'avis d'un mec qui SDF
qui a 58 ans qui sait bouger le cul et
qui a fait plein de travail et qui
aujourd'hui est un média indépendant qui
s'adresse au SDF ton profil je te le dis
m'intéresse autour d'une table parce que
c'est un profil que je n'ai pas et un
profil et et que j'ai c'est un point de
vue que je n'ai pas autour de la table
donc réfléchis tu me donnes pas ta
réponse tout de suite tu peux attend
visibilité pour votre médiia
aussi tu peux tu peux même attendre la
semaine prochaine prends ton temps mais
sache que tu auras une liberté de ton
vraiment alors à 100% je te dir jamais
ce que tu dois dire ou pas dire et tu me
dis tu me donnes ta réponse mais en tout
cas voilà je t'ai fais la proposition un
petit message bien sûr alors il y a une
association qui s'appelle rau SDF c'est
une amie qui s'appelle Sarah tu la
connais je croiscord d'accord voilà et
qui aide les femmes surtout les femmes
sont sans abri bien bon c'est une
association de la 1901 reconnue par
eloasso donc si vous voulez faire un don
c ass ne vous gênez pas et il y a pas
que celll d'association il y a une tonne
d'associations des toutes petites qui
font d'énormes gestes
des grandes qui font des petits gestes
mais aussi des petites qui font des
énormes gestes et puis il y a un truc
que j'ai appris aujourd'hui qui me
dérange j'ai appris que la police
chasser les marudes dans Paris bah ça tu
et ça ça me met sérieusement les boules
parce que les marodes souvent c'est des
petits jeunes des quartiers qui viennent
pour donner à manger au SF ou pour
ramener les couvertures ou quoi que ce
soit ça j'aimerais bien que ça c'est des
truc qu'on sa Pasut qu' VI par
exemple sud de la France où les flics
ils mettent une amende au sansabri parce
qu'ils ont une canette de bière dans la
poche fermée sauf que et je fait un peu
de droit si tu veux qu'on t livresse tu
as deux solutions la prise de sang ou
souffler dans le ballon sauf qu'ils le
font pas donc et les mecs ils se
prennent une amende de 135 € c'est des
trucs comme ça voilà faut venir le dire
ça faut le déoncer et puis bon il y a je
veux dire une chose si vous voyez un
sansabri moi je pense que vous êtes tous
comme moi si vous voyez un sansabri
faites-liui un petit coucou dites-liui
bonjour demandez- su un café une
couverture ou quoi que ce soit ça ça ça
vous coûte rien du tout gratuit c'est
gratos un sourire c'est gratos c'est
c'est peut-être ce qui réchauffe le plus
le cœur un bonjour vous allez bien vous
avez besoin de quelque chose pas hésiter
quoi voilà c'est surtout ça le message
c'est merde on est il y a il y a il y a
presque 500000 sans abris en France je
vais te dire un truc hein il y en a un
qui nous gouverne qui vont pas être
content on est capable de donner 412
milliards aux militaires qui sont 350000
sur 4 ans on n'est pas capable de donner
la même somme pour lutter contre le
sansabrisme le sansabrisme c'est
seulement 2 milliards et demi par an je
te jure et ça ça me fout les boules
patris qu'on dit exactement la même
chose dans cette émission je te le jure
on dit un moment on l'a dit on a dit
quand il a fallu sortir la planche
habill
pour le covid pour autre chose on l'a
sorti donc je suis d'accord avec toi
làdessus c'est ce que je dis et c'est ce
qu'on dit tous les jours et un moment
voilà un moment on peut pas avoir autant
de gens qui sont dans une telle détresse
aujourd'hui en France ne crois pas tu
sais je vais te dire moi je je je je
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et moi on était tu le
sais s'entendait bien et puis après on
s'entendait moins bien parce que moi
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je pensais au départ
que c'était un mec qui voulait aider
justement les gens comme vous et qui
allait faire des choses pour les gens
comme vous après je me suis rendu compte
que c'était plus un carriériste et ça
m'a dérangé mais je vais te dire moi je
suis pas dans le truc où je veux qu'il y
ait plus de pauvres je voudrais qu'il y
ait plus de personnes qui s'en sortent
et plus de riches voilà je je suis pas
parce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon il partle
d'un principe c'est la haine antiiche et
la haine antiiche ça fera pas qu'il y a
qu'il y aura moins de pauvres et qu'il y
aura moins de SDF au contraire il faut
vraiment il faut déjà que les plus
riches aident
les ceux qui sont dans dans la plus
grande précarité
mais il faut que les plus les plus
pauvres deviennent plus riches et son
sortent il faut que le travail rapporte
plus aujourd'hui les gens qui
travaillent doivent gagner plus y aussi
une chose importante qu'il faut dire il
y a 700000 emplois par an en France de
disponible il y a 7 millions de chômeurs
on fait comment pour faire bosser 7
millions de chômeurs on peut pas tous
les faire bosser sinon les les un sur
les autres donc il y aura toujours des
pauvres il y aura toujours des chômeurs
en France mais c'est pas parce qu'on est
pauvres chômeurs SDF ou précaire qu'on
doit être j'ai je me suis senti dénigré
je te dis honnêtement parfois je me sens
dénigré par les propos de chroniqueurs
ça me dérange parfois
JeanMichel ça t'embte pas tu dis des
trucs qui me dérangent dér- que est-ce
que tu un exempleat politiquement quand
il il a dit des choses je suisésolé de
dire ça j'ai trouvé que parfois des
paroles venant à la limite du RN et ça
m'a énormément dérangé pour moi qui suis
de
gauche Patriot a une différence entre
Patriot et nationaliste patriotim son
pays
patriote c'est aimer son pays et ceux
qui compos être nationaliste c'est aimer
son pays mais pas ceux qui le compos ran
moi je suis assez d'accord avec toi et
si j'ai pu te heurter je m'en excuse par
que c'est c'est pas le but que ce que
cyil a dit c'est réellement les et ce
que tu as dit c'est les valeurs qui nous
qui reflètent notre émission c'est en
plus je comprends j'ai pu je comprends
que tu ai pu être heurté mais vraiment
ça me touche réellement car c'était
vraiment pas le but et nous on pense on
pense qu'il faut aider les gens qui ne
peuvent pas travailler pas ceux qui ne
veulent pas travailler et c'est là la
nuance ils sont minoritaires ceux qui
veulent pas
exactementcoup il y a des sans abri qui
veulent être sans abri qui ont choisit
son mode de vie et ça faut respecter
aussi ça bien sûr alors j'ai un j'ai un
SMS très drôle qui me dit espèce de
connard tu m'emmerdes tu es une onde
pour la télé tu as une place pour moi
autour de ta
table merci très drôle merci en tout cas
bonah je te laisse réfléchir Patrice tu
viens tu reviens vers moi je prendrai
ton je peux te je te contactera tu me
dis et réfléchis te prends pas la tête
tu as un petit peu de temps si c'est pas
cette semaine sera la semaine d'après
voilà euh merci en tout cas d'avoir
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous de
cette idée la vérité maise idé c'est une
super idée il est formidable parce qu'il
est lui-même il est sincère il
transigera
pas parce il est lui-même en plus il est
tellement sincère que c'est touchant
faut venir Patrice vous serez vous-même
à l'émission comme vous V êtes dans la
vie c'est pour ça qu'il faut venir donc
je suis à côté de toi g pas de
problème mett à côté ça va être
incroyable plaisir sur un B c'est une
chance d'être à côté de gens avec qui on
est pas d'accord pour justement c'est ce
qu'il a dit c'est ce qu'il a dit ce
qu'il dit je suis pas d'accord avec les
idées de redine de Jean deanmich
Jean-Michel c'est pas pour ça que j'ai
cché très respectueux toujours merci en
tout cas Patrice d'être venu et on se
tient au courant très vite et
franchement je pense que c'est au
contraire c'est un destin ça c'est le
destin merci beaucoup merci juste je
voudrais dire euh tous les gens qui vont
faire des vidéos sur les réseaux
pourulter peutêtre je vais leur propose
un truc PASAT trist pour le coup c'est
vraiment un profil que je cherchais je
vous dis la vérité c'est vraiment un
profil que je cherchais et et qui
manquit dans l'émission donc voilà c'est
pour ça que je te le propose aussi c'est
pas comme ça c'est pas pour te faire
plaisir ni pour faire un effet d'allon
c'est vraiment j'ai pas fait cette vidéo
pour faire je sa mais vraiment tu savais
même pas que j'allais t'appeler rien je
suis sûr que tu croyais même pas que
j'ais tapper non à midi on m'ael pour
venir lui il a pas du tout calculé patri
jamais il pensait que j'allais le faire
venir et que j'allais lui proposer même
lui il était même pas au courant que
j'allais lui proposer ça et moi c'est
quand j'ai quand j'ai discuté avec toi
là j'ai j'ai eu l'idée maintenant j'ai
pas eu l'idée avant voilà voilà c'est
tout merci en tout cas d'avoir été là on
se retrouve dans un instant les chers
à